how to start your own clothing line
i get asked this a lot a lot of people
like us are interested in creating their
own clothing line and it's a great
potential idea but so many people fail
in it
and i don't want that for you so i got a
question from one of my uh
youtube viewers love you guys extreme1
who said my question was about creating
a clothing factory i want to start my
own clothing line
i have designs what should i do should i
make a deal with manufacturers first
or what i'll wait for you so
let's back this thing up okay here's the
problem with most clothing lines and how
you can avoid their failure okay most
clothing lines
go broke they go bankrupt they go under
the main reason is you have a design
okay you have a great idea for design
you think it's great
you go out and in the clothing business
you want to go make a deal with the
manufacturer it's a quantity game
okay they don't want to deal with the
little guys they don't want to deal with
the
one-offs because it's not great business
for them they'd rather deal with the
guys who are doing
tens of thousands of t-shirts all the
time all the time all the time hundreds
of thousands more more and more
it's too much work done with a new
account and then just goes under
and there's too much cost for them to
set all that up so they don't want to
work with you
they're going to ask for some minimum
that for you is going to seem
huge and for them is going to be nothing
right if they want you to order a
thousand shirts
that for them for a good manufacturer is
tiny but for you
might blow your budget and a lot of
entrepreneurs that say okay well this is
the only way to do it
so i'm gonna go do it and they make that
investment and they buy a thousand
shirts
and then it just sits in their basement
or sits in their closet
and nobody buys them and now you're
stuck what do you do you're stuck in all
this inventory
all your cash is tied up in this and you
can't do anything to grow your business
maybe you had the wrong design maybe had
the wrong idea and you end up giving up
here's the way to do it the best way to
get started with your clothing line okay
this is really important
you are the artist come up with the
designs if it's yourself or if it's
people that you're working with
a team people who inspire you whatever
it is you have your designs
go out and start selling these things
before you make an investment to buy a
thousand shirts
okay use websites like wordens or
caffrey press or something just to get
started
find a website that will allow you to
upload your design and even if you're
not making anything off of the first
ones
your whole point here is two things
okay one you're proving that your shirt
will sell
and two you're building an audience i
put some shirts up on on wardens for
example and now i'm working with
uh a clothing line i've got a deal
coming up that i'll i'll
talk about in a later video when i'm
more ready for it
but you can put up your shirt online and
it can be high quality it could be on an
american apparel shirt it could be on
whatever you want
but put your design up online and sell
them
through an online store and even if you
make
nothing okay your goal here is not to
make a ton of cash
off of your first shirt it's not going
to happen they take
a huge cut or everything right if
they're taking 20 bucks a shirt how much
you're gonna sell this thing for
that's not your goal your goal is to see
if it works
see if you can help promote this thing
because if you can drive traffic
if you can get interest if you can get
people saying i love this thing this is
the greatest thing i've ever seen i'm
going to buy 10 of them
if people are making orders then you
know
that you're ready to go out and make a
deal with a manufacturer
and instead of investing your your money
into inventory that doesn't sell
you can invest it into marketing this
thing and seeing what works
and you have a an audience list
customers of people who've bought a
shirt
even though you made no money off of it
when you come with your next shirt
they're going to buy it again and again
and again and again for each shirt you
come up because they love your stuff
they love your style so stop spending
money
right now don't go out and buy a
thousand shirts don't go make a deal
with a manufacturer put it online
create an online store order a few so
you can show it off
and start selling see if the idea works
prove to yourself you should be the the
harshest critic
prove to yourself that you can go out
and make this a business
the people will buy this thing give
yourself the evidence
that you need that you can go out and
make that investment to buy a thousand
shirts
and then make that deal with the
manufacturer because you know that your
next shirt
is going to be a huge hit believe
for those who watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more and if you have a question for
me or comment about this
video leave it below in the comment
section i'll make a video response for
you
thank you so much and i'll see you soon